hey y'all flickers of fear time once
again
going all the way back to 1961 for this
movie
this is a movie that honestly had
never been on my radar at all i had
never heard of this movie
you know it just kind of to me it just
kind of came out of nowhere which is
really weird because this totally sounds
like something i would have been into
i guess what happened i had never heard
of it until shutter
added it to their roster probably like a
couple months ago and i was scrolling
through and i'm like oh man i never
heard of that and i kind of read the
description i'm like oh man that sounds
pretty good
and i was like oh i got to get around to
watching that so i finally did
now it's i guess it was restored in 2007
i don't know if it was previously like a
lost movie or whatever but it does seem
like one that
a lot of people don't really talk about
anymore even though
it's pretty notable for um for several
reasons but also for being kind of the
first
starring role of dennis hopper now he
had been in movies prior to this
obviously but this was his kind of first
star turn and he's like super young in
this i just couldn't even believe it
and it's like he plays a character so
unlike a lot of his later characters
that it was like really
i don't know it was like really weird
and like kind of jarring to watch
but yeah so as i said this came out in
1961 it's called night tide
now this was directed by curtis
harrington and he did um
he did a lot of like kind of horror
movies experimental movies
he seemed like he was real into i don't
know kind of like occult stuff
and that kind of thing so he seemed like
a really interesting
dude i think even later on um i think he
was the advisor on
gods and monsters uh that movie that
came out when the [ __ ] did that come out
in the 2000s sometimes it was about uh
james whale
the guy that made uh frankenstein so
there's that as well
but this movie is just i'm
okay so i'm gonna recommend this if
you're into
60s horror if you like
carnival of souls you will probably
really dig this because the vibe of it
is very similar
also if you like um val luton's movies
from the 40s particularly cat people
then you'll probably dig this as well
because this has almost no i don't want
to say it's the same story as cat people
because that was kind of more like a
werewolfy type of story
but um this is kind of similar but
different monsters and i will say that
they don't make enough movies about
killer mermaids can i just say that
right now so i'm like really really
happy
that this movie is about a mermaid
maybe they leave it ambiguous like i
said if you have not seen this
it's on shutter i think it's also on
tubey if you don't have shutter and you
want to watch it for free
so because i probably am good i'm going
to spoil it because like i said this is
one of the ones that
has kind of an ambiguous and like leaves
a little question mark over the end so
you're not really sure
entirely of what happened um so you know
and
it's kind of hard to talk about if i
can't talk about that so spoiler alert
i'm gonna say that right here
so some of this was also kind of
inspired a little bit
by um annabel lee the edgar allen poe
poem and indeed there's like a quote of
it at the end
but so like i said it was made in 61 but
i don't think it came out till 63
then it kind of flew under the radar i
suppose
restored in 2007 and then shutter just
added it so i've seen like some other
channels covering it recently just
because shutter
kind of rediscovered it i guess because
like i said i had never heard of it
previous to this
even though this sounds like it'd be
right up my alley so you'd think that i
would have
so what we have here we have uh dennis
hopper is playing a dude named johnny
drake
and he is uh he's just recently joined
the navy
and he's on shore leave in santa monica
now they do kind of establish a little
bit about his past it's so funny like i
said it's so funny how [ __ ] young he
is
and he just plays kind of like this
naive like this wide-eyed innocent type
of character because it's almost kind of
like i think he says at one point
to one of the other characters which
i'll get to in a minute that he says you
know his dad
died and like left him and his mom and
him and his mom were really close
and then when his mom died he didn't
really know what to do with his life and
he just wanted to see the world so he
joined the navy but he hasn't really
been in the navy that long
and he hasn't really been anywhere he
said you know the farthest i've been is
the hawaiian islands so it's like
so he's still very very young and very
inexperienced
so he's on shore leave and he goes into
this place called the blue grotto which
is kind of like a jazz beat nikki
kind of club and he goes in there and he
sees
this beautiful dark-haired woman
and so he goes over and starts talking
to her and she's like pretty dismissive
at first you know he's kind of like hey
this music's cool in it she's like yeah
i'd like to listen to it so like shut
your yap
like not like that but i mean that's
kind of what she meant
so he kind of persists and he's just
like oh okay sorry and but he still kind
of like sits there it's like offers to
buy her a drink and she doesn't want him
to
and um all this other stuff she's not
rude but she's kind of like
yeah back off leave me alone but then he
gets even more intrigued by her
when this weird looking older woman
with like these black clothes and this
creepy like eyeliner and stuff
like comes over and starts talking to
her in a foreign language
and this like seems to upset the the
younger woman
so and then she's just like yeah i gotta
go so then she leaves but dennis
uh dennis i call him dennis because
that's the actor's name
johnny is the character's name so johnny
follows her though because he's
kind of in the space of like five
minutes has become totally obsessed with
this girl so he starts pretty much
following her home
and finally she's just like okay fine um
she says her name is maura
and that she lives in an apartment over
the merry go go round because this is
all set at the santa monica pier so it's
all
it's a very carny kind of uh atmosphere
which like i said reminded me very much
of
carnival of souls this isn't as surreal
as that
but it has kind of the same vibe to it
so finally maura agrees um she's like
okay well
let's have why don't you come over my
apartment tomorrow and i'll make you
like some brunch or whatever and uh so
he says fine
so they kind of meet and start hanging
out
and it starts kind of developing over
the period that they're sort of you know
with this burgeoning
romance that they're having there's some
other people
that start kind of warning him about her
now the first thing that he finds out
is that her job is that she is a
sideshow attraction she's more of the
mermaid and she says yeah i put on like
a mermaid costume and i lay in a
tank that looks like it has water in it
and people pay 25 cents
like to come look at her so it's like
you know a sideshow
so he thinks that's pretty cool and he's
like you know can i come see it and
everything so when he goes to see
um her in her mermaid in her little
mermaid outfit
or whatever there's a guy who's you know
outside the tent like trying to get
people to come in and his name is
captain murdock
and he basically says that it's
established later that
maura is kind of like his ward kind of
like his adopted daughter type of thing
he's like yeah i found her she was
orphaned like on this greek island
and um so i brought her here and raised
her and now they kind of work together
so she's kind of so he's kind of like
her father figure or whatever
but as time goes on like i said um
it starts to become maybe
uh you know just from what people are
saying
that maybe she's not a fake mermaid that
maybe she's for real a mermaid
now she seems to believe this as well
because i mean captain murdock pretty
much straight up
tells johnny look she's a mermaid
and you know when the moon is full or
whatever like all the other sea people
like are calling her back to the ocean
and she might get a little murdery like
right around that time so he's like and
i like you kid and i wouldn't want
anything bad to happen to you
um so maybe you should like break it off
and another um person that he talks to
is like this other
this other guy and his daughter i think
and they kind of run the merry-go-round
and some of the other concessions and um
that daughter is like super into johnny
too so she's like not even making a
secret of it
so she basically says um yeah we don't
really
you know we're just trying to we're not
trying to like you know step on your
dick or anything but
weirdly two of maura's last boyfriends
that she went around with uh
mysteriously drowned so we don't know if
she killed them
or you know but it's a little weird so
we just thought we we just thought we'd
let you know that
so as the story goes on as i said maura
seems
uh also very convinced that she is
indeed a mermaid and that during times
of the full moon
the sea is pretty much calling her and
she's afraid that she's gonna
kind of get sucked out there and like
back in with the sea people
and like i said interesting too
interestingly too this woman
like the older woman with the eyeliner
and the and the flowy black clothes and
stuff
she's also kind of seen a few times like
sort of like following maura around or
following johnny around
but the strange thing about that is that
one time johnny follows her
and he ends up at captain murdoch's
house like quite accidentally
but then the woman has sort of like
disappeared and nobody else seems to
have seen her
so i kind of want to get into that a
little bit too because that's kind of
the one thing that sort of left a little
bit ambiguous
so everybody's trying to convince johnny
that maura is a real mermaid she thinks
she's a real mermaid he starts having
these really weird
dreams about her like with tentacles and
you know of them like making out on the
couch and then she has a big fishtail
and stuff like that so it's just this
really creepy i don't even i don't know
if i'd call this
a straight-up horror movie it's almost a
kind of is
but it's more like it's not like as
creepy or as scary as carnival of souls
like it doesn't have like
that creepy straight-up horror imagery
but it definitely has some creepy
like unsettling imagery it's almost kind
of like a suspense
mystery type thing with like a little
bit of horror element to it
but it's just i don't know like the
atmosphere of this is just like really
really great i love
movies that are sign up kind of set in
like carnivals fairs things like that i
just like that atmosphere
and this just has that even though a lot
of it is even shot in daylight it still
has this really creepy vibe to it that's
kind of like hard to explain
so so yeah so as time goes on you know
he's like well you can't believe you're
not really a mermaid come on that
doesn't really happen and stuff but she
seems really convinced
and he even finds her like one night
he's um having a like a bad dream but he
wakes up
and he finds out that she's like walked
out to underneath the pier and she's
under there like freaking out like
they're calling me they're calling me
and all this other kind of stuff and he
has to like drag her back into the house
and then interestingly she asks him you
know then he kind of starts well maybe
she is a mermaid or at least she
believes she's a mermaid maybe she's or
at least maybe she did kill those dudes
so maybe she's crazy
uh which also that would not be good so
he's real reluctant so basically she's
like oh well let's go out diving
one day and he's kinda like yeah i don't
think i really like that idea but
um you know she's like yeah come on
it'll be fun so they go out to this kind
of remote spot that she knows oh there's
a reef down there
and so they're both diving down there
and pretty much within like two minutes
she goes and cuts his air hose and then
takes the [ __ ] off so he has to like he
lives
like he has to get to the surface really
quick and then he gets back in the boat
but she doesn't come back now
interestingly after this it's okay so
after all this happens it's like i said
it's very ambiguous as to whether she's
an actual mermaid or not
but then after this bit happens johnny
is freaked out
he doesn't know where she went and so he
goes back to
uh you know the the shore or whatever in
the boat
and then the next day he goes back to
the fair
and captain murdoch is still there like
out front just hey
here come see more of the mermaid or
whatever and so
johnny kind of like sneaks in there and
maura is in there but she's dead
right like the corpse is in there and so
he like wigs out then captain murdock
like runs in with a gun and he's gonna
like shoot
johnny and it's just this big crazy
thing so then at the end they have this
kind of like scooby-doo like reveal kind
of thing
where captain murdock basically says
no maura's not really a mermaid but when
i adopted her
like from this greek island she was an
orphan or whatever i didn't want her to
ever
leave me so i convinced her
that she was a mermaid and that every
now and then
like the sea would call her and stuff
like that he's like i just didn't want
her to get
like he started doing that mostly like
when dudes started sniffing around you
know when she started dating
guys um so actually captain murdock
was the one that had killed the two
previous boyfriends
for hanging around too close and maybe
taking her away from him which is a
little creepy when you think about it
because he's kind of like i said he's
kind of like a father figure as if that
wasn't bad enough he also
sort of convinced her not only that she
was a mermaid but also convinced her
that she killed them
so so she's believing like i said much
like cat people where she thinks oh
every time i have sex i'll turn into a
cat and kill you
so it's kind of like that kind of thing
she's like every time you go out with a
dude
you're gonna turn into a murder mermaid
and you're gonna kill them
and so captain murdock had like sort of
developed this whole thing
to basically keep her uh under his
power under his you know he he seemed
like he didn't seem like a
sinister character necessarily but he
just seemed like kind of a sad
lonely old man that you know she was
like the only thing in his life and so
he didn't want to lose her
to someone else so he like came up with
this really elaborate crazy story that
he got her to buy into because he kept
repeating it to her like from when she
was a kid
but the weird thing about that so even
though it seems to be solved no maura
was not really a mermaid you know
you know captain murdoch was the one
that killed the boys she didn't do it
even though she did uh straight up try
to kill dennis hopper though
but like i said that was because she
thought she'd killed the other two boys
and she thought that was just
what she did but it
still left a little bit ambiguous
because
they never explain the older lady
that you see a couple of times like the
one that came up to maura
in the in the club like at the first
like in the first five ten minutes of
the movie
and like talks to her in a foreign
language and maura seems to understand
what she's saying and is like freaked
out by it
and then later johnny sees her and
follows her
and you know he ends up at captain
murdoch's house but then everybody's
like hey do you see a woman walk by here
and everybody's like no we don't know
what you're talking about and captain
murdock didn't know who that woman was
or anything like that
so we're we don't know if
maybe she really was a mermaid and like
maybe this woman was like one of the
other mermaids being like hey [ __ ] you
need to like come back into the ocean
because you're a mermaid
and so like maybe she was trying to get
her to come back or
if captain murdock had for whatever
reason like hired this woman to just go
around being creepy and like
pretending she was they call her water
witch in the um
in the credits at least they don't call
her that in the movie but
you know maybe captain murdock hired and
then he pretended to johnny that he
didn't know who she was or what the [ __ ]
was going to what he thought of what
woman i don't know what you're talking
about
so there's so there's kind of some
ambiguity there and there's also this
really great scene
where johnny gets a tarot card reading
from the woman that was also in the
atomic brain if any of y'all are like
mystery science theater fan
so it was like as soon as i heard her
voice i was like oh my god
atomic brain i recognize that voice but
uh but yeah so she gives him this really
elaborate like tarot reading
and some of the stuff she says in there
is
i don't know could be interpreted that
maybe there was some supernatural [ __ ]
so maybe so
it's left ambiguous i guess who that
woman was they never explained it
whether maura was actually a mermaid or
not you're led to believe not but then
there's kind of like some question marks
left over it too
so you know it's it's just it's a really
weird creepy eerie
kind of suspense thriller type of thing
and like i said there's not enough
movies about killer mermaids somebody
needs to rectify that
so as i said if you're really into cat
people if you really
i really really recommend this would be
a good double feature with carnival of
souls this incredible souls just
are like really seem like they would go
really well together so
definitely if that sounds like your kind
of thing and you want to see dennis
hopper
looking like a naive 19 year old or
however old he wasn't this movie was
made
then i would definitely recommend it
it's just like i really really dug it
i really liked the whole creepy
atmosphere of it it's just it's hard to
explain because it's not like a scary
scary movie
but there's just something i don't know
just kind of like unsettling about it
which i thought was really cool but yeah
so it's on shutter
at the moment uh it looks beautiful the
cinematography is beautiful
and i believe it's also on 2b for free
at least in the united states
if you don't have a shutter subscription
so uh definitely go check it out and uh
let me know if you thought that maura
was actually a mermaid or not because
i'm kind of conflicted about the
situation and who that woman was
uh so yeah so that will do it for this
flickers of fear and i will see you guys
on the next one
bye